the jurogan experience i
went down a pathway with queen's gambit
where i was like is this a true story
because if this is true that there is
this beautiful young
flawed woman that's very interesting to
me it's not a true story
there's a lot of people on the internet
who think that it is a true story uh
it's based off a book
but chess sales are through the froof
you couldn't get a chess board when that
thing came out
really yeah isn't that hilarious like
like chess sales were going
crazy which jess is a beautiful sport
and um much like long-form conversation
we have here
long-form game yeah i mean months you
could really play
they they get into speed chess in that
uh yeah in that show but
you can play chess forever man yeah i'm
scared of chess
i'm terrible yeah at chess and i don't
want to get good at it because uh i
think it's something that i would get
absorbed with i remember there was a
time where howard stern
got obsessed with chess and he was
taking chess lessons when he was talking
about it on the show
yeah yeah and i remember thinking oh
he's an obsessive like he'll he'll
in that event i think he eventually
bailed and stuff stopped doing it but um
i've had problems with video games
i've had problems with pool i used to
play pool competitively
and i guess i get real obsessed with
games and chess seems to be
like the most intense of all
intellectual games it's going to trigger
the [ __ ] out of your
intellect what what kind of billiards
would you be like nine ball yeah
nine ball ten ball straight pool i
played a lot of all those games but i
played a lot of pool
a lot i played a lot of tournaments yeah
to the point where um i have
i have a table in my old studio i have a
table at home
um i collect pool cues i have a bunch of
pool cubes full cues are [ __ ] cool oh
yeah especially when they
unscrew and you take you get the [ __ ]
briefcase and you know
uh color money what's in the case in
here
doom that is such a good movie
my brother todd got obsessed with pool
and we had a pool table in our basement
but it was like classic midwest basement
and that it couldn't
it wasn't fully unobstructed so we had
this
we had this like weight-bearing pole
right here
if you ever had to go like in the in the
uh
the middle you know you had to do all
this creative [ __ ] short stick we sawed
one down
yeah but todd got really in the pool my
dad took us to the nine ball
championships
one year down in like west virginia and
we're like you know
these guys are like excellent at pool i
mean they'll run
racks after racks and it was like wild
how the brain
is not how my brain works with my
brother's brain we go like one ball
there two ball there is going to move it
off here
and that's like geometry chess it's all
like that yeah
it is and it's also finesse and touch
and feel
yeah and great sounds yeah it's also a
sport that thrives on drugs
really yeah like an adderall type
situation yeah
because they would gamble and they would
play for you know 15
16 hours the thing about pool is that
they would play
until someone quit and so uh
guys that was like the gentleman's you
would never quit on somebody when you're
ahead
right like if you if you quit on someone
when you're ahead people be mad at you
right and they didn't like if you played
like for two hours and you won like a
thousand dollars and you like uh
we'll play again tomorrow they'd be like
[ __ ] you stay and people get mad at you
they would really get upset and you
would have a hard time getting a game
because right you'd be a guy so you have
to
wipe out your opponent until they say i
can't do this
yeah it's like it's like to the death to
the death yeah
it's like like amongst top players
unless
there was an agreement like you could
make an agreement
yeah you could make an agreement we will
play two sets
i'll play you two sets race to 20 right
for
x amount of dollars per set but we're
gonna make an agreement right now of two
sets
right that's rare though right most of
the time they would post up
and they would play until guys went
broke like the hustler yep the hustler
with jackie gleason
and paul newman that was the theme of
the movie is that paul newman's winning
for like 15 16 hours right and then
jackie gleason has character and paul
newman is self-destructive
and eventually jackie gleason overcomes
him and i don't know i've ever seen the
hustler but obviously that's
great who's helped paul newman get cast
and call her money
oh that was like for sure that was the
it was that was the rich color
yeah okay that's that's what i want the
color of money was the sequel
okay i didn't realize that yeah they
were both written by
i think walter tevis is the guy who
wrote it um but i've read the books too
they're
pretty similar um the the the character
in the second movie is different like
there's a lot of things in this
in the color of money they're different
than made for tom cruise and but
in the hustler paul newman uh
retires because like he's he makes a
deal with this mob guy
okay and at the end of it he quits
playing and
so he's he's retired from pool and then
he meets tom cruise
many decades later i see so the hustlers
takes
the hustle takes place i think in i want
to say
63 okay somewhere around then that's
when that movie came out
and so color money is like 1980
i loved coloring it's great that that
made pool go through the roof
people started playing pool like crazy
and people people in the pool world
have always said they need a movie like
the color money
right and they yeah pool hall junkies
some people liked but it never really
had the same impact
it wasn't that good it was okay like
some people liked it but
they couldn't really play right if a
person who plays pool like i watch it
would be very frustrating for me
cause like if you were watching someone
play tennis dude it [ __ ] infuriates
me
any commercial with tennis they're
holding the racket
wrong it's like just get anyone that
plays tennis to
quickly advise you on the right grip and
now i'm like
but all i can focus on is that and i
believe caller money
i i remember reading about it that they
like locked tom cruise yeah
in a room for three months and taught
him how to shoot his grip
crews worked with mike siegel okay and
mike siegel is one of the greatest pool
players that's ever lived right
multiple time world champion like
literally one of the all-time greats
i've had the opportunity to play mike
siegel i played him i hung out with him
he's a great guy
and he was also left-handed just like
tonight
yeah and he taught tom cruise and tom
cruise looks like a guy who can play a
little
paul newman in the hustler does not
really look like a guy who can play
he does a lot of goofy [ __ ] right but
jackie gleason could play
jackie gleason literally plays like a
professional
you watch jackie gleason in the hustler
like he spent a lot of time playing pool
when he was a kid like
look jackie gleason was a guy who drank
and smoked and hung out in pool halls he
was a man's man he was a
he was a you know a wild dude yeah and
he could [ __ ] play like
really play how did you get introduced
to pool
i hurt my acl okay i tore uh my
acl ligament and i couldn't work out for
a while and uh when i couldn't work out
me and my friend john
start he was a comic as well we started
going to this pool hall in white plains
new york
and uh i just stumbled upon one of the
great pool halls in that area wow that's
one of the reasons why i moved to new
rochelle cause i could be close to white
plains
because i was addicted to this pool
people get [ __ ] addicted to the pool
that's how my brother was dude what does
this say
yeah the video game doom got its name
from the film yeah the video game doom
got its name from tom cruise opening up
that
uh because they want to know that yeah
because when he opened up the case
and he goes what's in the case he goes
in here
i remember that with his dumb accent yes
he was
he was excellent in that film that's
what john
yeah that's what they wanted to uh john
carmack wanted to
say to the video game world when they
when they released doom what's in there
because this game is so crazy in
comparison to everything else yeah so
that's where i came up with
i came up with the name yeah it's
something like the the
i forget the character's name and gwen
queen's gambit but when she kind of lays
in bed and looks up and
watches the world you kind of see like
pool players look at the
at the table that way to death to death
yeah this goes here and uh but there's
with pool there's
execution right the difference is
you could miss a shot where you're in
perfect position whereas with chess
you just move the thing you don't have
to think about your physical hand-eye
coordination and skill so
nerves don't play a factor as much in
terms of your ability to move your body
so with pool the thing that excited me
about it was
it was about controlling yourself under
pressure
and you're literally applying a certain
amount of
pressure to a ball and you want to
control the revolutions
that the ball makes over a long period
so it's all touch and feel
and the more you play the more and you
get in what they call
dead punch or dead stroke where you
understand
exactly how much impact and exactly how
hard to touch that cue
exactly how much how much impact it has
on the ball to just
perfectly place that ball in position
for the next shot
it is uh it's a great game my brother
had a book called how to hustle your
friends at pool and used to read it
and uh we'd have friends come over and
they would always get mad that he was
reading a
book but but he loved it it's a great
gambling sport yeah it's cool it's a
game where people get
mad if you pretend you're not good right
and it turns out you are good yeah isn't
that what the hustle is
yes yeah right what's interesting about
it is it's also a game where people
lie about how good they are right like
men
always want to pretend they're really
good at pool it's a weird thing yeah
like if guys don't know you play like i
play
pretty good like i'm a b player yeah
which means like i'm not a pro
but if i practice for six months and
really dedicated myself you'll be
excellent i can run racks yeah i've run
out
three four racks in a row i can play a
little yeah and if i played a lot i
could i could
i could play on a very high level but
most people can't like i played for
years eight hours a day
i played every day i always played i
took a cue on the road with me
everywhere i went
when i when i would go on the road and
do do gigs i find pool halls and i play
pool all night long that's great that's
what i always did most men lie
like they tell you like you say do you
play pool oh yeah are you good yeah i'm
pretty good like
oh are you really like how good are you
oh i'm good i always beat my friends
pretty good you're like do are you
really good like have you ever played in
tournaments
they'll lie and then you play them and
they suck they suck golf is like this
what do you shoot i shoot about 100. you
go out there and you're like you [ __ ]
lie
or you cheat everybody cheats at golf
everybody gets so surprised when they
ask me if i'm good at golf and i say i'm
okay and they say what are you shooting
i say
110. they go no there's no chance i get
out there and you really count my
strokes in the time that i moved the
ball and the time that it like followed
the rules i shot at 110.
but everybody lies is that a good number
no no
what do what what what's a good number
par is 72. but i guarantee you he's
going to say he shoots in the 90s and
when we go out there we actually play
he's going to shoot like 125 like a
typical station
90 ish is probably a good number yeah 90
is a good number i could get there but
but you would need a lot of time you
need some time yeah and and you don't
cheat
but everybody like yeah is fun it's true
people lie about what dude the worst
if you're a single guy trying to like
pick up girls and you got to play pool
with them and they're [ __ ] like
garbage did they beat you if a girl
beats you a pool good luck getting laid
good luck they don't want to [ __ ] you if
they can beat you at pool everyone knows
that catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background by using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify
app go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience